hi there steve kaufman here uh it's a
sunday morning
um i really appreciate it when i get uh
interesting questions and comments from
uh
those of you who have the patience to
watch these videos and so the next few
videos i'm going to answer these
questions
uh one question was from a link user who
was very flattering in his comments
about how exciting he finds it
to use link in fact even addictive
and his question had to do with
whether one can study more than one
language at the same time it's a subject
that's come up before and i'm going to
provide you my views on that
there was also a question from the same
person about
how many words do we need to know so
i'll deal with that in another video
and also i had someone who commented
about this sort of
stress factor this block that one
sometimes feels through this sense of
stress when learning a language and how
can one deal with it so that'll also be
in a subsequent video
but today i want to talk about this
issue of learning many languages
um obviously and this particular
commenter is a user of link we have 21
languages i find myself in the same
situation
there's so many languages that i would
like to work on
uh either to improve languages where i'm
already fairly along fairly well along
or to start a new language
uh it's always been an issue for me for
example trying to pull myself from
russian in order to start check
pull myself from czech to do romanian
uh ukrainian i've recently dabbled a bit
in polish and yet this morning while
doing the dishes i was listening to
korean
because i'm gonna be in korea in march
and so there's always and it's a bit
you know i was recently in france
uh with with my wife and we visited a
store called
decathlon or decathlon
which sells a tremendous variety of
of sporting goods clothing for sports
fitness equipment uh ski
golf
you name it
cycling
a phenomenal array it's a fantastic
store i wish they had stores like that
in canada
and it made me realize that if you walk
into an environment where you are
surrounded by
this tremendous assortment this
tremendous choice of things that you
might want to acquire
it encourages you to want to acquire
more and i think that's part of the
psychology behind these stores
the home depot
in the u.s or costco or any of these big
box retailers they put so much stuff in
front of you that our natural
inclination is to consume more
i think something like that happens to
us as language learners when we are at
the stage where we have yet to master
our first foreign language
we feel that it's very difficult we'll
never get there we we're overly critical
of our own uh
results and achievements uh we don't
have that
confidence that we're gonna get there
and and of course that's very very
important as i said before if i'm
looking for something at home and i know
it's at home
i'm going to look for it until i find it
but if i think it might be at the office
or it might be somewhere else i'm not
quite as determined when looking for it
because i'm not so sure that that it's
to be found at home and so for that
first language we're not so sure that
we're going to achieve the level that we
want so at some level we don't try as
hard as we should once we've been
through one
foreign language and a second and a
third we're now fully confident that we
can do it so now it's just a matter of
allocating our time and now
language learning itself becomes more
addictive because we've had that sense
of satisfaction of achieving success
all these languages become very
attractive to us we see now like if
you're at link you can look at the drop
list there's 21 languages and they've
all got content there to listen to and
read and gee you know i want to do them
all and
and so it's very easy to be distracted
as is generally the case today with
anything having to do with the internet
there's so much choice there
that it's very difficult at times to
stay on task
a couple of things about multiple
languages personally i prefer to focus
on one new language at a time because it
requires so much dedication and
concentration
however as i've said before i can dabble
or refresh another language where i'm
fairly well along but that would be the
maximum two languages like now i've
decided i'm going to do korea
still contain continue to do my
ukrainian but i'm not going to do polish
for now even though
again it was tempting to do polish
because the vocabulary is very similar
to ukrainian and now that i've done
czech and russian ukrainian i want to
get in in the polish so i had to make a
decision i'm going to be in korea in
march
i should really get the level of my
korean up so that's going to be my focus
as well as listening to ukrainian and
some extent russian as i follow events
taking place they're more out of
interest in those events than as a
deliberate language learning focus my
language learning focus is going to move
to korean
okay so
first point is focus on one at a time at
least 80 of your effort that is my
preference now i want to be very clear
in all this there are other people who
are happy learning five languages at the
same time but if i'm asked what i like
to do i prefer to focus on one at the
time 80 percent
the second thing is you can focus on one
for three months and then move to
another
and one of the surprising things that i
have found and i've had it confirmed by
many other people
if you leave a language for three months
six months
and then go back to it again
you end up being better
okay you are initially rusty but as soon
as you
get back into the swing of that language
you are better
now i used to explain this to myself
in terms of a
sort of uh something that i put into the
oven that's still baking
and so that uh you know i
noticed on many occasions i would for
example
i was at one point listening to a lot of
chinese at home
then i had to go to sweden so i focused
on swedish and when i came back to my
chinese i understood it better
and
i thought somehow that that learning
effort continued to gestate in the brain
somehow
but i don't think that's what it is i
think it's more i provided a link
earlier to a video by a professor bjork
who talked about interleaving and
the importance of learning and
forgetting and re-learning and
re-forgetting and re-learning that that
process
is much more powerful
than
staying with
one set of information you know trying
to nail something like we often do for
an exam
that that in effect we may in fact
retain it for the exam but it won't stay
with us whereas things that we forget
relearn forget relearn
we
are able to learn those better and it
might just be that that's the
explanation so if you were to go three
months on language a and then leave it
and then do three months on language b
when you come back to language a
again with the intention of focusing on
it
uh you will be initially a bit rusty but
as you recover to where you were you'll
end up stronger understand better better
able to express yourself so
while i i
recommend at least based on my own
experience i have a preference for
focusing on one language as long as i'm
sort of
motivated most motivated to focus on
that language i know that all the
languages that i leave like my czech
like my romanian like my ukrainian even
the little bit that i did in polish
whatever i did there is not lost and
whenever i choose to pick that up again
it'll all be still in my brain and as i
revive that as i relearn it from
wherever it's
disappeared as i start to recall it and
relearn it again i will know it better
than i knew it before so the answer is
insofar as my own learning habits are
concerned i prefer to focus on one
language at a time but i'm not afraid to
put the language aside and focus on
another language for a while because i
know that the effort that i have put
into
that language that i've put aside is not
wasted and when i go back to that
language i will
after that initial sort of rusty period
i will be stronger
than i was before so i hope that perhaps
a little bit confusing but i hope that
answers uh your question and i do
appreciate questions and comments and if
i'm able to respond to them and use them
as uh content for my video i'm i'm only
too happy to do so thank you for
listening bye for now